فوز المنتخب السعودي على الارجنتين امس
لسه متسيد تويتر يعني لا الحقيقه هو متسيد
كل المنصات والاحاديث ورغم كل المباريات
اللي ان لعبت من وقتها لسه هذه المباراه
والنتيجه حديث الاعلام حول العالم الضربه
القاسيه اللي اخذتها الارجنتين من
السعوديه وعلى فكره ترى هذا الوصفنا احنا
مسي هو اللي وصف الخساره بهذا الشكل هذه
الضربه خلت الصحافه الارجنتينيه ما ترحم
منتخب بلادهم صحيفه كلارين الشهيره قالت
انه الارجنتين ووقعت في شباك السعوديه
اللي صار بالعثره التاريخيه اما صحيفه
اوليه فمن عناوينها كان الحلم تحول لكابوس
وصحيفه لنا ثاني يوم في هذه كانت الاقصى
وعنوانها او الاقصى وعنوانها كان سقوط
مدوي ما توقعنا بدايه زي هذه وهنا
الاوصاف اللي قالها ميسي بعد المباراه لما
قال احنا الان مثل الميتين هذه ضربه قويه
وما في اعذار الاعلام العالمي والعربي
والسعودي احتفل بالمنتخب بشكل كبير ام على
تويتر في السعوديين والعرب مكملين
والاحتفالات والتنكيد والاجواء الروعه
الماهد يدفعليا الصور الفستان المقاطع ما
وقفت
يا اخوان
لقد وليت عليكم ولستوا بخيركم
فان رايتموني على حق ولا على باطل تاكلون
عهد التسيب
والدلع والسربته انتهى السعوديه
كان
كاس العالم مش في ماتش ودي السعوديه يا
باشا الله يفتح الشباك ده يا ناس السعوديه
كسبت الارجنتين في كاس العالم
محمد العويس حفل كده انت ده انت هتصاحب
الراجل خلاص بقينا مستوى واحد محمد بلعويس
احفظ ال 11 اسم دول سعودي
ميسي
[موسيقى]
ايش اللي صار
يا سلام
[موسيقى]